The next part of the process is reflectance.
That is where the incoming illuminance reflects
off an object. We are very familiar with the
ability of shiny surfaces or mirrors to reflect
light.
In high school physics we learn about the
rules of reflection from such a surface, where
the angle of incidence equals the angle of
reflection and we refer to this as specular
reflection. Now this is not saying anything
about the color change that occurs during
reflection, it is simply talking about the
geometry of the reflection process.
We refer to this as specular reflection, which
is related to the Latin word for mirror. We
met William Herschel before, who is the guy
who discovered infra-red radiation and he
made the big mirror in his telescope from
a type of metal that was called speculum metal—it
was reflective alloy of copper and tin and
it was used in the old days for making telescope
mirrors.
A more realistic model for the way light is
reflected off objects is what is called Lambertian
reflection, and Lambertian reflection differs
from specular reflection in that the incoming
light is reflected off in all manner of directions.
This is the sort of reflection that occurs
from a dull or matt surface. Sometimes called
diffuse reflection and it is named after Johann
Lambert, who was a physicist in the 1700s.
The intensity of the light that is reflected
from the surface is related to the angle of
reflection, and what is interesting with Lambertian
reflection is that it leads to the brightness
being invariant to the observer’s angle
of view.
Now the moon is a really good example of Lambertian
reflection. We know that the moon is a sphere,
but when we look at it, it appears to be a
fairly uniformly bright disk, apart from the
craters and the seas. So the reason that it
appears is to be uniformly bright even though
the light has been reflected, is proportioned
to the cos sign of the angle, is that the
area of the region that we are looking at
appears to change in size. Here is an exaggerated
example: I take this particular patch of the
moon and most of the light from that patch
is being reflected directly up, it corresponds
to an array something like this. If I take
a patch that is down near the pole it is clearly
going to be inclined with respect to my field
of view. So it is going to have one of these
rays down here associated, so it is going
to be reflecting less light, but the area—the
apparent area of this patch—is smaller because
I am looking at it obliquely. So if I consider
the brightness to be the ratio of the light
being omitted to its surface area, this is
invariant to the view angle.
So we have just looked at the geometry of
the reflection, the direction of the rays
being reflected form the surface as a function
of the incoming ray. Let’s talk now about
how reflection changes the color of incoming
light. Here we see a red house brick, the
plot here shows what we call the reflectance
of the house brick; that is, the fraction
of light that is reflected form the brick
as a function of wavelength. And it is quite
a complex curve, we see that there are some
parts of the spectrum where it reflects a
large amount of light and there are other
parts of the spectrum where it reflects very
little light.
The right hand graph shows a zoom into the
visible part of the spectrum.
Now we can see that the red brick reflects
not very much blue light in the region, say
400 to 500 nanometers, but it does reflect
a fair amount of the red light that is falling
down, say the light between 600 and 700 nanometers,
and that is why it looks red to us, it reflects
more red light then it reflects blue light.
So this is the spectrum of a red brick, different
minerals have different reflectance spectrums
and here we see the reflectance spectrum for
a number of minerals. If we have an instrument
that can measure the reflectance at a number
of different wavelengths, an instrument perhaps
like a spectrometer or a hyper spectral camera,
then we can measure one of these particular
curves and we can match it against a library
of known minerals and use it to identify what
minerals are within the scene.
So to recap, incoming light, we refer to as
the luminance and it has got a spectrum E,
which has got a function of the wavelength
lambda, and we have the reflectance of the
object itself which we refer to as R and it
is also a function of lambda.
So the light that leaves the apple, which
we refer to as the illuminance of the apple,
I am going to use the symbol L and it is also
a function of the wavelength, now L at any
particular lambda is equal to E
at that same lambda multiplied by R at that
particular lambda. That is the spectrum of
the light that is leaving the apple, the function
of the spectrum of the incoming light, and
the function of the reflectance of the apple.